you break down the cohorts of people who
adopt bitcoin right so we have
individuals we have corporations we have
financial institutions we have nation
states the first one being individuals
majority of the individuals that are
already in bitcoin are not going to use
the banks right the banks are not going
to get our bitcoin that's i think pretty
clear
new people who want to come in that are
either older they're not digitally
native they for some reason have not
felt comfortable uh buying bitcoin they
are the likely individuals to go ahead
and put bitcoin into a bank right they
trust their bank whether they showed or
they shouldn't there's a trust with the
brand at their bank and so they're more
willing to trust the brand they know
than a brand that they don't know that
somebody told them to go create an
account somewhere and do something so i
think there is a cohort of people it's
just not the people who are already in
that would trust the bank with their
bitcoin i would not then you go to the
uh financial institutions i think the
financial institutions can't wait to get
the banks in the game because now all of
a sudden they get to use the same
counterparties that they've been using
that their regulators are comfortable
with that their auditors are comfortable
with that their internal teams are
comfortable with that their compliance
departments are comfortable in fact they
already have the relationships et cetera
it's a recreation of the world that we
used to have again i'm not arguing this
is a good thing i'm just telling you
what i think is going to happen so
there's a lot of financial institutions
that i think this would be a big deal
because now if you're a bank you get to
put on your balance sheet but also if
you interface with a bank they can hold
your assets for you you can buy and sell
with them et cetera um and then you can
also use this as collateral i think
people forget like
you know michael saylor microstrategy is
a perfect example is as you use this
asset as a collateral he could go and he
could borrow a bunch against it because
he's got billions and billions of
dollars of it right and so i think that
that's going to be a big piece of the
system moving forward then you go to
corporations i absolutely believe that
corporations would love for their banks
to be able to custody this stuff for
them or to hold it and allow them buy
and sell from it rather than going to
the crypto companies again not arguing
that it's a good thing i'm just saying
that if you're a fortune 100 company do
you want to trust coinbase which again
has a high degree of trust because it's
the kind of most well-known exchange
when it comes to uh cryptocurrency in
the united states but would you rather
trust coinbase or would you rather tell
everyone hey jp morgan holds my bitcoin
right of course wall street your
investors regulators auditors etc
whether they should or not they're going
to assign more value to those legacy
trusted financial institutions rather
than going especially if there's some
insurance built on top of it absolutely
i mean imagine if there's fdic insurance
on your bitcoin account that's a huge
advantage right and remember there are
insurance uh on bitcoin accounts today
coinbase and gemini those are the two
that i know uh i believe sofi as well
has insurance but the two that i know uh
uh distinctly are coinbase and uh gemini
both have self-insurance and i believe
that they both have set up captive
insurance which basically means that
it's not just hey we put some money on
our balance sheet off to the side if
anything happens we'll pay out they've
actually taken their own money they've
put it into a regulated entity that they
technically don't have control over and
then those insurance companies
specifically are used to ensure uh their
accounts it is not fdic insurance right
so that's like the holy grail of
insurance is fdic but it is at least
better than no insurance so we've kind
of taken a step in the direction fdic
would be the big unlock and then lastly
you have nation states right and i
actually questioned whether nation
states would use the banks or not
because if you think about it el
salvador
if
they are going to get into bitcoin would
they really trust a u.s based bank
i don't know right
well what if there's a bank locally
would they trust the local bank let's
say a salvadorian bank i don't know
so there is an element of you're going
to get a bifurcation some people are
definitely going to trust the bank some
people aren't going to trust the banks
and some of it also i think is there now
might be a switching cost in reverse so
a lot of people think of the legacy
world switching into the crypto world
that's a high switching cost i already
have a bank account at name your
favorite large bank uh why do i have to
go sign up for a cryptocurrency exchange
account right but if all of a sudden
i've now gone through all that work i've
got my compliance team got my auditors
my regulators everyone comfortable with
my crypto kind of native setup or my
vertically integrated crypto setup
then if now my bank accepts it am i
really gonna switch back
i don't know that's what we're gonna see
but i do believe that if fdic insurance
comes to accounts where you can hold
bitcoin that would be a massive
inflection point in terms of uh adoption
and also i think that there's a very big
uh argument that this would usher in the
financialization of bitcoin there are
some very bad
negative impacts of that but the
positive impacts would be around higher
prices in u.s dollar terms because uh
you've got higher demand now for the
asset and it's a fixed supply so so it's
it's a nuanced conversation but i don't
think anyone had on their 2021 bingo
board fdic is gonna figure out how to
get the banks in the game of bitcoin
this early